I think the question is how do you create a
climate for the private investors so that we
can get the industrial base of the cities turned
back around so that the minorities have come to
the cities looking for a place to live and a
place to work can begin to again find the kinds
of opportunities that have been available
for other ethnic groups that have come here
over a period of decades if the jobs are anywhere
they're here Chicago's labor climate is the envy
of the nation but to make the jobs accessible to
the labor supply we've got to make it attractive
for industry to locate inside the city we've got
to have good public transportation we've got to
have adequate housing and decent schools near
the job source and these dramatic turnabout's
won't happen unless Chicago's minority
citizens have political representation
it takes political muscle to bring forth the
kind of decision-making and financial support
and makes these things possible politicians
won't deliver the goods unless you show them
you can deliver the votes this isn't the way
they teach it to you in American history of
civics but it is the way they teach it to you
in real life I'm worried about Chicago one of
the most political cities in the nation because
our best estimate is that in the recent primary
only 25 percent of registered black voters
went to the polls many of our communities
have no public servant in that in the residence
at all I just cannot accept a docile apathetic
black Chicago the answer to this question that
everybody has raised and I've heard it from each
microphone is actually first of all something
that I think that would embarrass ourselves if
we were to insist on a hit count in here
today and that is full voter registration
effective political education strong organization
and then effective mobilization then collectively
going down down get an hours that's the difference
senior high school graduation must be seen as
the passage of Rights into adulthood on that
graduation day our night we must put our diploma
in one hand symbolizing knowledge and wisdom and
to the voter registration card and that other hand
symbolizing power and responsibility the next step
after border registration is a make certain that
you vote because the vote lists people is the
hopeless people all we have to remember is that
Harry Truman won the presidency by one vote per
pre served throughout the country John Fitzgerald
won by a half a vote throughout the country
and I just got through with a very grueling
race in which I won the race to be reelected to
ward commitment in the Third Ward I only won by
11 votes let's participate make your voice heard
if we are going to really really exert the power
that we've got to exert it politically we are not
going to do it by going it alone and I'll form a
coalition name but it's gone toward our goals
our goal is to establish a national network to
increase political awareness and black communities
and to supplement the ongoing voter education and
registration drives when it comes right down to
it we've got to do all we can to help ourselves we
can't count totally on government or institutions
as they are now that's why the league has been
deeply involved in voter registration program
making the city work has got to be the biggest
American imperative we've got because the city
is America we're in urban people more today than
yesterday more tomorrow than today the Urban
League has to be the catalyst motivator prod